l'hôpital freneur testait depuis quatre
ans l'efficacité de la réalité virtuelle
pour soulager la douleur et le stress
chez les enfants l'expérience est
maintenant terminée tous les petits
patients iront droit on est vraiment des
très bons résultats au niveau des études
pilotes puis qui montrait vraiment une
dysfraction des enfants durant les
procédures douloureuses ce soit avec les
enfants qui avaient eu des brûlures les
enfants qui avaient des procédures
orthopédiques très douloureuses donc ça
fait vraiment une différence l'idée
c'est de capter suffisamment l'attention
de l'enfant avec un jus de réalité
virtuelle pour lui faire oublier qu'il
est en train de subir une procédure
douloureuse ou anxiogène par exemple le
prélèvement une injection ou des points
de suture on parle de douleur importante
et de la douleur aiguë courte mais
importante donc ça peut aller jusqu'à 6
7 8 sur 10 de ces temps la pire douleur
et ça fonctionne très bien une étude sur
90 enfants indiquent un taux de
satisfaction de
84% chez l'enfant et ses parents le
petit alab est atteint d'une maladie
génétique rare qui exige de subir
régulièrement des procédures médicales
douloureuses et stressantes
c'est un urgentologue qui a mis sur pied
l'entreprise de logiciels de réalité
virtuelle la réalité c'est que on n'a
pas toujours les outils nécessaires pour
arriver à nos fins les médicaments
souvent c'est trop fort beaucoup
d'effets secondaires ça nécessite
beaucoup de surveillance la gamme de jus
développée par paper plane s'adapte au
type d'intervention médicale et aux
capacités de l'enfant maintenant il y en
a une multitude d'unités qui circulent
partout dans l'hôpital et sont toujours
à la disposition des professionnels de
la santé qui veulent utiliser avec leur
patient donc maintenant c'est rendu
pratique commune au Chinese
estime que 3500 patients n'auront fait
d'usage d'ici 2024 et 17 500 d'ici 5 ans
ça devrait être dans tous les hôpitaux
d'enfants ça me coûte presque rien du
tout c'est avec un simple entraînement
avec quelques paires de lunettes et
ensuite tout est là ici normalement
Grondin Radio-Canada Montréal